they thank you very much Roni a our
focus in this webinar is going to be on
business model innovation for
established companies which is a very
interesting and challenging topic
I've been studying and teaching business
models for more than twenty years and
being in Silicon Valley
our focus tends to be a focus on
startups and when we think about
business model I like to use the analogy
of building the house when you go and
build the house you would probably want
to have a blueprint first that will
guide you through the process and in a
very similar way before you go and build
a company the business model is like a
blueprint of the business that helps you
build the company in a deliberate way
and let's think about what are the
elements of that blueprint so the first
element of the blueprint or the business
model is the value creation model that
tells us how we're going to create value
for our customers in how we're going to
deliver it to them the second key
element of the business model is the
profit model that tells us how we're
going to get compensated for doing all
of this work in the third and most
important element of the business model
is the logic of the business that tells
us why it's going to work in what we do
in our different courses is really learn
how to build that house how to put
together that blueprint in a deliberate
way of course once we kind of put this
house together
the first time it's exposed to rain it
usually collapses and that's what
happens to most startups a lot of the
time in what we do is test and retest
and retest learn from each test and
rebuild our business model again and
again and again until we managed to put
together what I call a viable business
model in the startup world we can afford
to iterate and fail multiple times
because we don't have that much to lose
we don't have that many customers we
don't have that many employees and if we
ultimately
fail what will happen is that we can we
can charge that failure to learning
right so we've learned something new we
have a good story to tell so our losses
are a bounded on the other hand when we
build a business model in an established
company it's an entirely different story
what happens is that when we need to
take our existing business model and
build a new one it's a little bit like
building a house when you still live in
it and that has a few problems if I mean
if you experienced that with customers
in our existing customers actually love
our business model and they say why do
you need to change it you don't need to
change it you want to everything to keep
going the way it has been going we just
like it that way
with employees who are used to doing
business in a certain way and they very
often resist the change and we sometimes
have shareholders who are risk averse
and they don't necessarily want us to
invest in a new and untested a business
model and they say you know give me my
quarterly results so we have all of
these challenges so when I see a company
that managed to change its business
model multiple times and do it again and
gain over more than a hundred years I
pay attention these are companies that
have learning and innovation in the DNA
and there's a lot we can learn from them
one of these companies is the fun group
that started this lien Fung a hundred
and nine years ago I've been working
with them over the past three to four
years and I've been really impressed by
the way they are responding to the
tremendous change that's taking place in
their industry I think all of us can
learn from what they're doing and we're
going to do that today it's a special
pleasure to have you online with us a
Leonard will help us understand what
makes the fun group tick our format
today is going to be farce a fireside
chat format and we'll open it up to
questions a little bit later but please
feel free to ask questions as we go
along so my first question to you
Leonard is the fan group
is a group of companies that touches
hundreds of millions maybe billions of
consumers a over a year but most of them
have never heard about it what is it
what is the fun group can you give us a
little bit of a background a little bit
of a background thank you hi and thank
you for that
let me start just with the brief history
of the group and then we're going to
come back to that a little bit later
when we talked about how we've changed
our business model so the company will
celebrate next year it's hundred and
tenth anniversary and as you point out
we have lived through a couple of world
wars we have lived through a few
financial crises we have lived through
the comeback much later to talk about
the switch in the world from global
production to global consumption and
we've been able to work our way through
that in a variety of interesting ways
with a number of interesting ideas so
let me start quickly with our history we
started 1906 in Canton and we were a
Canton based China trader I started by
Victor Fong who was our group Chairman's
grandfather we moved to move to Hong
Kong in 1937 and in 1949 to 79 before
China opened up we were basically a Hong
kong-based exporter and we were
exporting a number of goods that we
could make in Hong Kong less expensively
then could be made in the West were
needed by the west and we exported those
best to the west and a little bit to
Europe in 1979 a major event happened in
China opened up that opened up a vast
production opportunity for us and so in
1979 we grew into a regional trading
company with the ability to source from
factories throughout China to meet the
specific orders of our customers in the
West then in 1995 we began a little bit
of a switch and we moved from being a
regional company to basically becoming a
multinational group of companies and in
1995 moving into 2004 and then into 2009
we established large bases in Europe
large bases in the United States in
order to get closer to our customers so
we infected meet their needs in terms of
their requirements of the retailers in
the West
and be able to match that with our
tremendous sourcing capabilities in the
East so that's kind of a bit of a
history the group itself is kind of
interesting the group is basically
overseen by the part that I'm in which
is the the Fung holdings 1937 limited
it's the private entity that oversees
our public group of companies and in the
group of companies we have three major
parts we have our trading and logistics
company which we call Li & Fung limited
they're listed on the stock exchange of
Hong Kong we have our distribution
company which is called our global
brands group also listed on the stock of
change in Hong Kong but they are based
in New York and that's the group that
runs our licensed brands across the
world the third group is a retailing
group also based in Hong Kong made up of
7 different businesses which we have
everything from toys sales and
distribution to circle-k stores to
high-end men's clothing and quite a few
distribution channels in China a little
bit more specifically about the group
when I take a look at the trading group
we have two different businesses as you
know we have what we call an agency
business which is the business we're
primarily a US retailer or a European
retailer places an order for either a
garment accessories shoes and we go find
the best place to source that from to
meet their quality and/or delivery
requirements and we ship that back to
them store ready for a particular
commission the second part of our
business we call it trading this
principle of business where we in fact
get further upstream into the design
product development in fact even making
complete collections for our retail
customers and that group of that group
of companies primarily operates in our
we call hard lines furniture area Beauty
area fast fashion and then we have a
third group logistics that group handles
in-country logistics primarily in fact
primarily exclusively in China and
Southeast Asia and then we have a new
group that we started in this three-year
plan called our vendor support services
which is working toward helping our own
factories that build their capacity to
compete in this digital economy but then
the group has a couple of are they're
interesting we call that EU ad features
if you look over there to the side of
the slide you can see something called a
fun global Institute which now renamed
the Asia Global Institute which is a
think-tank that primarily focuses on
bringing Asian issues to the global
policy table and we're working at a
number of things and that entire
research capability is available to the
group we have phone capital which is the
fun family venture capital firm and
there we primarily are looking in the
u.s. at investing in technologies in
front of the business so we're
constantly looking at what's happening
five seven even ten years in front of us
and which startups as a matter of fact
are playing in those areas and what are
the things that we can learn from them
we have a group in London that looks at
brands and our group in China takes a
look at opportunities in the in China in
addition to that we have my group which
is from the Academy which is designed to
accelerate learning across the group we
are also the group that houses our we
call our innovation catalyst on our
innovation laboratory and Explorium
which we'll talk about in a little while
19:06 foundation which is a fun family
foundation that invests in good works in
the area in the region and also has our
fungus collars program where we have an
excess of I believe two thousand
students on scholarships from Asia going
to school around the world so that's
kind of a look at the group in terms of
our in terms of our size just some
statistics about the trading company
alone from our 2014 annual report we do
annual sales of about nineteen point
three billion dollars which makes us one
of the larger players in our group as
you know we have 300 offices worldwide
approximately 25,000 employees about
15,000 suppliers or vendors that are
actually working for us every single day
and by the way as you know were an asset
light organization with minor exceptions
we do not own any of those factories and
so the unique value proposition for us
is taking the order for this shirt and
being able to take that single order put
it to a group of factories that can meet
the quality
and timeliness and distribution
requirements and then ship that to the
customer and so we do that for every
single order and that gets to a number
of we have 3.1 billion pieces that are
kind of shipped around the world but
they told me here the other day that I
said suppose I count all the buttons and
all the zippers and they tell me that
some point in time during the course of
a year we're running sixty billion
pieces of stuff through our system in
order to meet the the customer
requirements around the world so that's
kind of an overview of the group three
major companies the largest one is our
trading company it's the one you've been
working closely with here in the last
three to four years and we're going to
be celebrating next year a hundred and
ten years and we'll get into some of the
ways we do it that's great so when I
kind of looked in the press last week
actually I discovered that you had a big
event you opened at the Explorium and if
we look at the way they the newspapers
kind of reported that if we could go to
that slide they say they found group
launches the world's first retail
business model testing platform in
Shanghai so it's testing platform for
retail a so what is this Explorer you
mean why are you doing it that's a great
question and I today is I'm going to go
through a couple of slides there's an
opening slide from last Thursday I'm
gonna sit back we're just really happy
to talk about that today the Explorium
itself was created to allow our
retailers retailers that our customers
retailers that are not our customers our
brands and technology partners to
experiment with different omni-channel
business models to prepare for the
future of retail and I'm gonna go into
that in just a minute so that at the at
the high level that's the purpose of the
Explorium what it actually is it's
created on our campus in Shanghai where
we had a significant amount of space
that we thought we could use in a way
that's different from just off the space
given the future of retail so we created
Explorium which is basically a lab
easiest way to describe it
120,000 square meter destination
for shoppers in Shanghai and it publicly
opened last Thursday on the 24th the
phase one first phase one is for
children a much more family centric it's
a part retail experience it's a part
tech exploration and it's a part play in
entertainment because as we're taking a
look at retail as an experience in the
future and new frontiers of retailing
play and gaming becomes very important
so I want to just go through a couple of
things that that really are driving us
around that we take a look at this
basically and the Explorium and one of
the things we showed kids love to play
and in China as you know they have a
one-child family and so you can have a
child with two sets of parents and
possibly even two sets of grandparents
and the other closely related family
members so the one child come into play
and the one child coming to purchase
something that you want to purchase for
the child can bring a significant number
of people in one family to the to the
retail experience and so we wanted to
test was that for real
the second thing that we did was we
recognized in doing that the fact that
kids love to play that we're also using
digital online technology and the new
frontiers of retailing the acceleration
or the exponential increase in computing
power as we call it accelerates the use
of technology and the retail experience
I think a lot of people watching today
buy on their on their iPads or their
galaxies they buy mobile e they buy on
the computer they buy through bricks and
mortar all of those are going on and so
we wanted to be able to put the use of
technology into that lab for experiments
and we also understood there's a
tremendous drive toward personalization
and customization so we've been
experimenting with 3d printing and you
have an example here of toys that we can
experiment with which we're put in the
play together with the experience
together with the child and bringing the
family and getting them fully involved
in this whole process but I think most
important when we take a look at this is
to take a look at the reasons that we're
doing this and you talked about a
hundred years plus of existence and so
we'll talk about our our business
strategy in a little while and the key
word for us is context and in context we
take a look out into the future and this
is what we saw shaping the world today
and helping drive our thinking as to why
we need it and Explorium so we'll talk a
little bit later about the next billion
emergent consumers in markets like China
and across Asia so we took a look at
that as we all know that that's going to
be the largest area for growth in the
next twenty to thirty years we look at
the accelerating that technological
progress in disruption and we took a
look at the experience economy and we
said how do we put all that together and
when we put it together what do we get
and so we're fairly strong on scenario
building and William has a great example
that he uses at the beginning of each
three-year plan as he said we we paint
the scenario and then he takes a leap on
the stage and he literally jumps into
that scenario and he says we put
ourselves into that scenario and we look
backwards and say hey what do we have to
do now to get from where we are to where
we're going to go and so if you take a
look at the slide that's up there we saw
new consumers exponential technology the
experience economy and put it all
together and we basically said you know
it's really important for us to
understand how it works we can't do it
theoretically let's put it in place and
so in doing that that that enabled us to
think a little bit about what we call
the the Explorium premise purpose
philosophy and product so it kind of
goes back to marketing 101 we took our
our four P's and alerted them a little
bit differently so in terms of the
Explorium looking at retailers and
brands both the ones that we work with
and others that want to come in and
experiment with using omni-channel
processes or the omni-channel experience
with customers in China we're basically
saying look the change the world of
retail is changing we are and one of the
reasons that we are pride ourselves in
the organization for the hundred years
is we have a learning journey to go on
to move into this new frontier of
retailing and that learning journey we
want to take the customers that will
shop in a retail store and experience
the brand we want to take them through
that learning journey and so the next
thing we have is what's our philosophy
is we basically want people in this
learning journey to be able to be very
iterative to be very strategic and to
look at omni-channel that way and then
we'll have an experiment orchestration
platform with all the tools for them to
go ahead and do this so we put all of
that together and that really kind of
gets to the way that we look at all of
this there's three things that we see we
need to learn we take our 110 years of
history and the context we're looking at
which we'll talk about billion 2 billion
a little bit later and we say how cuz
all that work and what will be our
largest market and that is what do we
need to learn to win in this world and
learning becomes key for us so we have
to develop valid business models that
deliver as you point away the customer
value across the channel so that's the
omni-channel strategy we can help our
customers and brands and retailers think
about developing using an experiment and
go to your point a little bit earlier
you don't have to bet the whole store on
that one and as Victor says you don't
have to lose your shirt you basically
can have a small experiment set up a
hypothesis take the learning from it and
say dude do we want to go forward with
this idea so we'll persevere with it or
do we say that didn't work so I'm going
to pivot but I took some learning away
and go to the next one that means in
order to do that from our perspective
and the business and that's what the
Academy really is in the phone group to
do is we have to build a creative
capability and the creative capability
is not just installing or just basically
innovating for us it's really how do we
invent things an invention I think that
you'll talk about that creates the new
value in the marketplace and then
finally we need to have to make it work
and the the Explorium is a way for us as
an entire group to test how well we're
doing in a sense it's we call it kind of
Fung works it's our it's our lab so we
want to move basically exploration from
being a chore to the step of both being
a skill and finally becoming a habit
and the Explorium is all of that wrapped
into one retailers brands come
experiment with the space in China with
Chinese consumers test your hypotheses
we have the technology tools we have the
we have the support system for you to
what to do that IBM is one of our
partners in this one picot which is an
event management group that will set up
all these things then we have our
experimentation team so we say we want
you to come do this but for the fun
group itself it enables us to kind of
build this capability of invention and
experimentation of culture that becomes
a habit very interesting so when a
consumer comes to the Explorium do they
go shopping or do they participate in an
experiment
ah great question if this is the
laboratory we want to take them on a
journey so we are having the consumer
participating in experiments and by the
way they can also purchase something if
they want to while they're there as they
participate in this experiment and we
watch that behavior and we have various
pieces of technology which we can track
them as they're going through the going
through the Explorium we can of course
see how long they linger at a particular
spot we can you know see all those
things that the technology and the
frontiers are retailing enable us to do
and we can watch what they're engaged
with their experience is we also have
things them there for them to purchase
but that's not the main reason we're
there it's to have them participate in
the journey of the new frontier of
retailing and exploring the future
through their eyes which is the eyes of
the of the consumer at the moment in
China that's great
so can you describe for us one of those
experiments and what you're doing from
it yeah kids love to play I won't
mention the brand that we're doing this
with but we have the hypothesis that we
set up that if the this is for a shoe if
the children come in and they try on the
shoe and they walk around the store with
it they'll buy it but if they come in
and try on the shoe and go play with it
for a while the odds of them purchasing
that are even greater
so I'm simplifying a fairly complex
experiment that we
and a a board up there that you can sort
of see and we had a pad and back of it
and the kids could come up and they
could play on the board the play on the
on the pad and they could wave their
arms in relation to what you saw on the
screen and it turned out that the
parents were also doing the same thing
with the children so we had mother and
father and the children playing on all
of this they're watching the screen with
the character telling wave your arms
like this go like that and sure enough
we found out over time that the purchase
habits were in fact with that experience
they tended to purchase more shoes and
so this particular brand we found that
out and they are now installing this
entire game in a number of their stores
in China so that's an example of an
experiment that ran over a few weeks we
had a good hypothesis we tested it we
had the technology we had ethnographers
look at it we sat down with the brand
and said what did we learn what does the
brand have to do to implement it the
brands now taking it to their stores and
will also help the brand think about and
look at the how they collect the data
from all of that to see how it ties to
our experiment that's terrific
so so we talked about what happened last
week let's go back 110 years and kind of
think about alien fungus a start up in
how we changed its business model over
time okay so I think the I'm gonna go
back to the very first slide so that we
can kind of trace the trace of the years
through this so we started if we go back
in 1906 as a I want to say a Canton
based Chinese trader where Victor's
grandfather spoke English and his
partner was a trader and the two
together would sell to the to the
Western companies that wanted to buy
porcelain and fireworks
so we progressed from those two products
into additional products from 1906 1937
we moved to Hong Kong and then continued
to do that through 1949 and of course in
1949 China basically closed itself down
so now so during the first period what
was kind of the key source of
differentiation value that the company
created for its customers yeah
we actually were able to source products
at the right at the right price and in
the right quantity and get them
delivered to the port that they could
export from in China and the the family
the family business was very very
focused on what the appropriate products
at that time and we had a really good
sourcing Network and that's always been
a history of having a good sourcing
network and having deep relationships
with those factories that we could trust
them and they could trust us so it was
really the quality and strength of that
factory relationship and to be able to
adapt the Western requirement of of a
product to the eastern requirement of
production and what were some examples
of leading products during that period
well we moved with porcelain fireworks a
significant amount of time into toys
mostly in that mostly in that era in
that area and I'd have to go back and
look at the history book but the Victor
Fung has written a very good history and
you're gonna find a few other products
that we had in during that point in time
great in Victor Frank of course is the
chairman of as a chairman of the group
right great so let's go to the forties
and beyond
okay so 1949 China closes down and now
the if you will the Chinese factories
are now unavailable to us
so lien Fung then turned into more of a
basically a Hong kong-based exporter and
of course what was Hong Kong known for
in those days we were a toy exporter as
well as other hard lines and and an
apparel that was coming from Hong Kong
and primarily being shipped to the
United States so we were basically a
Hong Kong company and that's in Hong
Kong exporter and that was a story of
Hong Kong at that at that point in time
and that took us up through 1949 to 1979
in what happened in the seventies and
70s of course 79 we had another
significant another significant
breakthrough what had been closed to us
before opened up and prior to 1979 I
should say the
besides being a Hong kong-based exporter
we also were recognized as being able to
go to other countries Taiwan Thailand
other parts of of Southeast Asia and
find factories that could produce the
same quantity or same quality of goods
that we were able to produce in Hong
Kong
and so up to 79 we also began the
process of being able to become a
network Orchestrator which we continue
to call ourselves to orchestrate a
series of factories around a particular
customer requirement and we were one of
the only companies that could do that if
you remember there were tariffs and so
on when you ran out of them with tariffs
and one country you'd have to go to
another and we actually became very good
at doing that while we were based in
Hong Kong so then in 79 China opened up
and that opened back up our opportunity
to go back to the part we knew well
which was sourcing in China and this
that was also the story of Hong Kong
because Hong Kong and 79 the Hong Kong
entrepreneurs went back into China we
established the factories reestablished
their relationships reestablish the
sourcing network which is exactly what
we did and that was able to build the
company again from a Hong Kong to a
multinational group of companies and if
we take a look at that span we took at
79 roughly to 2009 we look at that
30-year period which for us is really
summed up in one set of words the
globalisation of production and I think
everybody in the audience is well
familiar with that we took advantage of
that opportunity we took advantage of
the arbitrage that we could get of being
able to aggregate within factories
around a particular area to the
distributed distribution process and
we're able to take advantage of all of
that because of our long sourcing
history and knowledge of the of the
China market so what would happen is
that the retailer wanted to have an
order with certain characteristics and
you could create a customized supply
chain for that order that we could and
let me in fact show you how that works
this is very interesting so I'm going to
move ahead a few slides here when we
talk a look at the globalisation of
production for us it's really dispersed
manufacture
and so we get an order from a company to
make parkas there's a picture that you
can see here it's borderless
manufacturing within the within the
trading company as you saw there was an
agency business and is trading this
principle of businesses so let me go
into the agency business at the moment
we have a US retailer that wants a
hundred thousands of those parkas that
retailer gives us the order we already
have a customer team that's focused on
that retailer and even maybe within that
team we have a subset of a team that's
focused on just this particular kind of
product and so that team will go first
of all get the design from the customer
make sure that everyone's clear on the
design then we'll go look for the
factories to make it as you can take a
look at this there's different pieces
that it will finally say well made in
Hong Kong the lining will come from
Taiwan other parts will come from China
the zipper will come from Japan the
shell will come from Korea and all that
will come together done by this one team
and that's wrapped around one order and
that will then be taken will order the
fabric the fabric from the mill will
then come to the factory where the
cutting and sewing is done the zippers
the buttons and so forth they were added
to it will tag it make it store ready
and give it to the logistics provider to
ship to the United States and so that is
the model that we use that's how you get
the 3.1 billion pieces of stuff that we
that we move through the system and
finished products and they're roughly 60
billion zippers and buttons and
everything else that goes with it now
great we talked earlier very briefly
about the business model being an
acetylide business model what does that
mean asset light is a really great point
with minor exceptions I talked to you
about four or five different steps in
this picture that's up on the screen we
don't own any of the factories we are
called a network Orchestrator that's
been captured in a Harvard Business
Review article and a couple of Harvard
Business cases and there's a network
Orchestrator we take the order we'll
take this parka for example and we will
orchestrate the factory's needed to
produce
parka we don't own any of them so we
have a roughly called 3070 rule we try
to give a factory take 30% of their
production but no more than 70% of their
production we do that on purpose so
particularly that we want the factory to
bring other brands items customers in
there so that we can learn from them and
they can learn from us it's all part of
a part of this learning process that
that we're committed to but basically we
don't own the factories and that gives
us a huge amount of flexibility and
agility so I know we were talking
earlier about what happens when a
natural disaster strikes like the floods
in Thailand for example well we can move
production from Thailand to Bangladesh
or from Bangladesh in the India and
because we have this large factory
network of 15,000 factories
quite a few of them are capable of doing
different things we can in fact move
that around to deal with pricing
differentials to deal with currency
issues to deal with natural disasters
but also to be able to pick the best set
of factories for that particular
customer at that point in time for that
order and that's very unique in in in
the supply chain world let's talk about
how the company makes decisions and a
one of the celebrated aspects of the
company's decision-making structure is
the three-year plan can you tell us
about that
yeah let's let's go to the three-year
plan here for the moment and again this
is well written up by the way so I'm
going to have to give a plug for
Victor's book called competing in the
flat world but what we are you we're not
even worried about saying these things
in the political world we operate in but
Victor and William tell a wonderful
wonderful story about how this developed
they looked across the border and across
the border they have a five-year plan
and Victor and William looked at that
and said that plans got some interesting
characteristics let me take the market
value and market issues away from what
the interest in characteristics is they
set a broad statement or broad purpose
and then they leave the individual read
to figure out the best way to do it and
then they hold him accountable for
results so we looked across at that and
said five years is too long and then
William said but you know most companies
have rolling three-year plans and so you
have a plan for this year six seven
months later or into the year you decide
to get ready for the plan for next year
and you haven't even finished getting
accountability for this year before
we're already rolling the plans for next
year and so companies have the plans
that continuously have this cycle to
them it's got some positive points it's
you know drilled right down to what's
happening in your environment today and
you make immediate adjustments or you
try to anyway but what you don't give is
the people in the business the stability
to be able to say I can work on getting
that objective and I can find multiple
paths to getting that objectives and I
can experiment along the way the beauty
of us it gives us a chance to experiment
during the plan and say what am i
learning and it gives me time to change
and it gives the people that work in the
businesses stability to say okay for
three years this is the plan now we do a
couple of very interesting things the
world changes a lot in these three years
and we recognize that we we work hard at
keeping our our revenue numbers and our
bottom line numbers in sight but we
recognize we have to change things
internally often as we find things as we
go this gives the people in the business
of confidence to say I can take a small
risk here you know I can experiment with
this one and then I can learn from it
and I can be able to implement it in the
second year of the third year plan or
even the third year of the third year
plan and then I can take all that
learning they have us ready for the next
three year plan so for us it's a way of
accelerating learning giving the
business stability and keeping your eye
focused on what the objectives are so
what is the the current three-year plan
that is a operation out that was the
2013 1 or 2013 to 2016 the one we're in
right now is what are the key elements
of that plan so let me take a step
backwards part of our growth over the
last 15 years or so since roughly 2004
last nine to ten years has been growth
by acquisition and that's been very very
carefully planned to be able to move us
into some different markets and closer
to the customers primarily in the United
States and in Europe so we wanted to
have good footholds in both of those
geographic areas and so we acquired the
companies that would give us those
footholds and put those together into
our into our trading and into our
trading and now Global Brands businesses
and we come to this came to this
three-year plan and said okay it's time
to consolidate that in the move away
from the acquisitive growth much more
into organic growth we also did
something else that was interesting we
took the this license brand business
which had been placed in different parts
throughout the trading business and
consolidated all of that and spun that
off into our global brands move based in
New York that's closest to where the
customers are that group is much more
focused on design and product
development and they in fact are
enhancing the value of licenses plus we
own a couple of brands in that group so
the the switch was to go from having
both the licensed brands and the
sourcing in our in one trading group to
dividing that up so that we could focus
in the trading group which we call our
four nine four group we could focus on
sourcing and providing value to
customers in both the agency and the
trading this principle businesses so the
second thing we did is we we really
enhanced the power of our logistics
group they have a laser focus on
infantry logistics in in China and
Southeast Asia
so organic growth for the trading group
consolidation an emphasis on logistics
to be able to really take advantage of
the opportunities that we had in the
China and Southeast Asia market and also
to give us the opportunity to do some
additional experimentation on the agency
and creating this principal model simply
because of the size we happen to have in
some of those markets so this three-year
plan is really focused on the
consolidation and learning and as we're
going to come back and talk a little bit
later about the billion two billion and
the in the context change in the world
from global production to a world of
overproduction and global consumption so
can you give us a glimpse into the next
three airplanes some of the drivers and
what the future is going to look like
okay let me go to to a slide that we
have here that begins to tell the story
for us from a geographic point of view
and a demographic point of view from
seventy nine to nineteen seventy nine to
roughly two thousand nine if we just
take a look at the globalization of
production China primarily in the and
then in Southeast Asia
we brought a there was a billion people
that came into the workforce and as we
all know a lot of the products that you
and I enjoy and the people watching
enjoy are made in that part of the world
and we took a look at the demographics
in that part of the world and we saw a
couple of really interesting things
again context for us is very important
and that ties to why we have a
three-year planning process the context
showed us that there's going to be
approximately 2.8 4 billion new
consumers coming up in that part of the
world so the people that have been
producing stuff are going to start
consuming stuff it's not that they
haven't been consuming they have been
and we've all talked about the bottom of
the pyramid and the opportunities that
offers but now we're watching that
numbers start to ramp up their not only
their incomes are beginning to rise
countries that have been at the lower
end of the economic ladder or beginning
to climb up that economic ladder and
they're now becoming consumers they're
not only becoming consumers but as you
know going through those countries and I
was just in Myanmar here a couple weeks
ago here's a country that's just been
opened up in the last two years and what
do we find everywhere I don't have that
my pocket that everybody has a mobile
phone and so we've seen the rise of
Technology accelerated use of
exponential increase in computing power
the accelerated use of technology and
then the rise of consumerism so it's
really this incredible growth of
consumerism in Asia and we looked at one
other thing we just looked at it in
pieces and looking at as we broke this
down we said China opens up but we also
have advancements in the supply chain
tremendous amounts of technology enable
us to be able to track everything you
take a look at the size of the container
ships now which we didn't have in 1979
all of the ways that we are connected
and understanding where all the products
it so now I ship a product and the
product itself is interesting but it's
shrink-wrapped with technology and I
really want to know all the information
the growth that goes with that goes with
that product so the next thing that we
basically saw as we move from the
advancement in technology we also looked
at basically the accelerating growth in
emerging markets and that's the billion
two billion but also with technology we
have the revolution and the consumer
interface I mean there's so many
different ways we can buy things now and
we can look at things we can search
that's the area that you've been helping
this with quite a bit on really
understanding customer intimacy in the
new value proposition but we also have
the rise of sustainability
considerations so in the globalization
of consumption we really are taking a
look at the drivers of the billion two
billion but I want to show on other
interesting things the shift toward
emerging markets is also accelerated by
a couple of things you heard the Chinese
premier talked about in the last year
and that's - Silk Roads or what they
call one road one belt and that is and
northern overland route which we've
always had and now we're looking at a
southern maritime belt and that's going
to connect 60 countries and
approximately four billion people so
context for us said that is a huge
opportunity now we don't want to lose
sight of the West I mean even though
this is all coming up the West is still
the tremendous market in terms of size
and it's not going away
so we looked at that market and we said
where are we really strong where are the
opportunities for us to differentiate
and it turns out that when we began
looking product by product that we did
which takes us back actually to our sort
of 1979
to 2009 we began to look at product by
product and saw in some areas we had a
tremendous amount of expertise and also
reach with a particular product area so
we began to say let's build some
platforms that are vertical that we can
take a complete product area pull it out
of the different parts of our business
and focus on that globally where we can
have technology that can enhance that
where we have product D product
expertise we have deep customer
expertise and because we have a deep
knowledge of the markets we can work
much more collaborative with
collaboratively with our customers
around finding new ways to create value
in the markets which takes us back to
that point on the Explorium as we can
kind of invent this stuff together so as
we look to the next three-year plan
we're taking a look at the billion two
billion we're taking a look at what the
opportunities provides us into that
market Explorium is our sort of space to
look at it and then in addition to that
we're taking a look at what we'll call
the product platforms where we have the
opportunity to take our size or scale or
scope and be able to create some
additional value in the markets for us
and our customers it's a fascinating
company and they have 17 more questions
but what I'd like to do is turn to
questions from our audience a number of
people have asked whether you'd open an
explore room for markets outside of Asia
great question we haven't discussed that
openly yet there are in the United
States quite a few quite a few retail
organizations that have their own
laboratories that have their own
innovation centers that are doing this
in their markets so we have to remember
that those are their markets because as
you know we are not in the b2c business
in either Europe or the United States so
one exception in the United States with
one brand but basically we're not in the
b2c business the retailers are they're
our customers they have their labs and
they
their Innovation Center so we would like
to say what are we learning in the
Explorium that we can help that will
transfer kind of a sort of innovation
blow back to you what are some of the
things that you can think about in your
home in your own home markets and we
invite them to come visit with us in the
Explorium and say what can you bring
that we can think about tailoring to the
Asian market I see we have a question
from a mic who is asking what we
when leading these transformations what
is one trade that the leader must have
for success you know I think I am we're
sitting here and in the Stanford
Business School and I think as I look
around the the academic and the
communication world the books are
stacked pretty high about the leadership
so there's a couple things that we think
are really pretty important and I'm
going to generalize in a moment then
come down to some specifics a key thing
for us given the type of company that we
are in and the world that's moving using
again the exponential increase in
computing power and the fact that we
have a globalization of production of
globalization of consumption probably
for us one of the most important things
is to have a global mindset is to be
able to have a kind of a deep
understanding of your own environment
and they have an understanding of what's
going on in the rest of the world to
provide context for your decisions the
second thing we look at very closely for
us is agility and its agility not only
in your individual thinking but also
agility and the organization's structure
and systems to be able to to take into
account things that are moving and so we
take a look basically at a global
mindset or context and agility or two
things that for us are very very
important I think the third point for us
is also having a very deep understanding
of how to talk to your employee culture
because I've seen and you've seen lots
of books written about it and everybody
talks about rolling out of culture or
changing the culture but we kind of look
at it and say the culture is there and
it's got certain things that it's very
that it values itself you know how do we
talk to that culture in a way that
they're willing and committed to the
directions we want to go and help us get
there so for us it's providing them the
context
and predictability and a good sense of
self and that really comes down to the
agility and then finding what we call
empathy in our leaders so another
question we have from our audience is
how do you process and analyze failures
what do you do when there's a failure I
think there's probably a lot of people
that want to know the answer to that
question this morning I am we do it in a
couple of ways one is and we borrowed
this from the concept of design thinking
that we we set out with a hypothesis and
those hypotheses we're learning as most
people are to get them what I'm going to
call tighter and tighter and tighter so
we're asking the right questions but
also have them flexible enough so we can
take into the fact that learning may
change change that hypothesis so we
start with a hypothesis we go out and
test it as quickly as we can we like to
use rapid prototyping as a method of
doing that and we're building that skill
in the organization so that it becomes
more of a habit rather than anything
else and then we we basically measure
what came out of that experiment so
setting up the hypothesis we have a KPI
or two in the middle of it we finish
with that and we say two things what
happened with the KPI but what else did
we learn and then we'll make a decision
about are we going to pivot and say that
didn't work that's a failure so we're
not going to go forward with that so
let's say the one you saw at the
Explorium with the with the kids on the
on the electronic pad and the screen
suppose it turned out that it turns out
that you know the kids the kids didn't
want to play so we would say well you
know so now what did we learn that the
kids didn't want to play and we might
pivot and say well they didn't want to
play that particular game so do we want
to try another one is this whole issue
of game design gets brought into the
picture at that point and we say maybe
we didn't design that properly so let's
go back and try it again or maybe we
didn't have the right customer segment
in there so we'll go back and play with
different elements of that hypothesis
and then if it doesn't work we just said
it didn't work so let's just take the
learning from that and we'll
the next one and with a company like
ours with the three-year plan again
within small parts of that ongoing we're
testing it intact customers are doing it
with us all the time they're asking us
anything simple can you change this can
we move to a different set of a
different set of machines to do this
particular kind of sewing so we can come
down with a very tactical level but
they're also usually asking us can you
change the design can we change a
process so we can get through product
development faster so those for us are
all experiments they're ongoing and the
business is just as a part of our let's
call our habit of the way that we stay
relevant that's great as you're talking
about there was a question with flashing
the screen which was what do you do if
in the first year we discover that your
hypothesis on the three-year plan is not
working and you answered that question
as the question was flashing on the
screen so that's great and we have one
one last question from Matthew who is
wondering how do you maintain supply
chain visibility now I'm just going to
use it in a simple words called
technology we have a staying inside Li &
Fung called smart supply chains and of
course the core is RFID technology in
one form or another so we actually we
track the order in fact we go back to I
want to call almost back to the future
with this one we have the technology but
you I am you and I may remember a great
Harvard Business Review article written
I forget how many years ago called
staple yourself to an order coming out
of manufacturing we all kind of learned
that but in a sense we staple ourselves
with technology to the order we staple
it from on the let me call it all the
inbound logistics of the order which for
us this might be a tech pack going to
the to the team that's gonna put it into
the factories to what's gone from the
mill to the cut and so from the zippers
coming in to the buttons coming and we
track all of those and then of course we
attracted all the way back to the
customer so we staple ourselves to the
order with technology
and we have a we have a very unique look
at IT because we've made a lot of
acquisitions we've had to do a lot of
what we call plug-and-play
so we can actually plug the new
acquisition into our system in order to
let that acquisition still have the
customer facing intimacy that it wanted
without being tied up in our bureaucracy
and so now we're a significant amount of
work is being done to eliminate
duplication between our system and a
customer system so that we in fact have
the customer saying you guys have all
the data you can manage all of this with
us together so for us it's basically
staple yourself to an order with the
accelerator to increase in computing the
new and improved stapler that's right
okay thank you very much for all of
these insights that was a great and I
hope it was useful for everybody I'm in
thanking Leonard Layne for joining us
and thank our audience for for spending
this hour with us I hope it was useful
and informative and we will be sending
out a recording of this webinar within a
week so that you can revisit this
material if you if you wish thank you
and have a good day
you